Andrew Chubb doing a fabulous PhD at the
University of Western Australia some new
data here
but he has spent a very long time
counting incidents in the South China
Sea and increasing levels of
assertiveness and he destroyed divides
them into three types decorative saying
something demonstrative sailing
somewhere coercive bashing into
something it doesn't mean that what it
means is changes so when things if
things go up and stay the same they're
not mentioned in subsequent years so
this is a kind of something new that
happened that didn't happen the year
before and of course what you see is in
general a rising process of
assertiveness however that's defined and
the red are things that we can worry
about where people actually died or in
the case of 1974 for example or 1988 or
whether or physical confrontations and
you can and a simple picture is that
things have become more confrontational
going way way back but it's coming it's
been episodic it hasn't been a
continuous rise there have been
particular incidents at particular
particular rises of assertiveness of
coercion at particular times if anything
you'll notice there's actually been a
slight drop off I mean the figures for
this year but apart from building
extraordinarily large islands I would
argue there's actually been a reduction
in some of the assertiveness in terms of
there being fewer clashes as far as we
know but that obviously has come as part
of the report you referring to the low
Institute about sir what was it called
passive assertiveness neurotic and now
in a in a previous life I look more at
the Middle East and and I used to
occasionally attend gatherings where
people would talk about law and show how
you know the Palestinians would show how
law was always on their side well it
hasn't really worked out for them having
the law on their side so law is
important but it's not everything I'm
reminded of an if you know the book by
Doug Henwood on Wall Street it's a
Marxist analysis of wall street and he
describes how used to work for a bank
and one day he got in the lift and there
was a policeman in the lift and he
suddenly realized that the light bulb
came on Heather that everything he was
doing all the way
relations all the compliance everything
came down to the gun on the hip of the
policemen in the lift you know if you
don't have coercion some form of
coercion then law isn't worth it we're
supposed to be living in a rules-based
order and stability there were sort of
phrase we've heard a few times these
past couple days it's about keeping
things as they are and if China wants to
change things then that inevitably means
instability now is the law a framework
is that a mandate is it a prohibition on
certain activities or is it merely a
tactic and I think this is we have two
visions or two versions of what law is
at stake in the South China Sea at the
moment now great powers don't need to
follow rules nobody can tell a great
power really what to do so I suppose it
tells us something about changes in the
international order when a great power
insists on rules because and you know if
they wanted to they could do what they
like but if there's a sense that there's
a transition coming then it's in the
interest of the great power and people
who support the current rules and
current order to make sure that those
rules are fixed in place for the
foreseeable future while it's still
possible keep the international system
intact now China was fully involved in
the unclass talks right from the very
beginning I believe it took over the
UNCG and 73 that's when the unclass
talks began so it should this should be
the kind of international law that China
should fully uphold and ironic I think
that it's reverting to the imperialist
version of international law historic
title this kind of stuff to try to
subvert the modern kind of international
law unclose that's been agreed in the
post-second World War era and now I
think china isn't likely to revise its
school textbooks in terms of its
historical view of who claimed what
first on the South China Sea and nor
were the strategic imperatives that Karl
and general Schaeffer spoke about
yesterday going to go away so China I
think he's going to continue to push for
whatever it can
yet I hate the use of poor world mr.
Thucydides in the South China Sea but I
think one of his quotes was the report
that the path will do what they can
under under under and the less powerful
suffer what they must well is that to be
the fate of East and Southeast Asia
China has his own view of what is right
for a regional arrangement of power in
East and Southeast Asia and it's not a
view that's shared by its neighbors so
that leaves us I think with three
options we can either have a Asian y el
tur where the world is carved up again
into the spheres of influence we can
have a war or there has to be pushed
back and push back requires a constant
jockey constant bashing of ships into
one another constant dialogue Overton
and and private and that I think is the
only alternative to the other two
outcomes neither of which is in the
interest of the region